j'appelle semblait comme ans thomas sabo
marque depuis quelques jours son nom
fait le tour du monde
abdelhamid about l'ennemi public numéro
un de la france serait l'instigateur
principal des attentats qui ont fait 129
morts et plus de 350 blessés
il se fait appelé aussi abou omar soussi
du nom de la région du maroc dans sa
famille est originaire ou encore abou
omar al bachir qui abou omar le belge
surnommé par certains le boucher de jaca
en syrie est considéré comme un proche
d'aboubaker al bagdadi le chef du groupe
etat islamique
il s'est fait d'abord connaître des
services anti terroristes comme chef
d'une cellule à verviers près de liège
en belgique
une cellule qui planifiaient des
attentats mais qui a été démantelé par
la police en janvier 2015
présent lors de l'assaut à baho davet
réussi à s'échapper
parti en syrie il s'est même permis de
narguer les services antiterroristes
incapable de l'arrêter il se vend aussi
d'avoir emmené en syrie son jeune frère
de 14 ans surnommé à l'époque le plus
jeunes djihadistes du monde
c'est pourtant ici à molenbeek qu'a vécu
abdelhamid about fils d'un propriétaire
de magasin de vêtements il a notamment
fréquenté ce collège catholique bon chic
bon genre de l'agglomération bruxelloise
à baho d'étain proche des frères
abdeslam surtout salah qui serait
toujours en fuite
à baho d abdeslam ont d'ailleurs déjà
été impliquée dans un vol avec
effraction en juillet dernier à
bruxelles
abdelhamid about avait été condamné par
contumace à 20 ans de prison dans un
procès sur les filières de recrutement
de djihadistes belge pour la syrie
depuis il aurait commandité l'attentât
raté contre le thalys le 11 août dernier
et un autre
quelques semaines plus tard qui aurait
visé des salles de concert et des stades
à faire de faire un maximum de victimes
mais le 13 novembre selon les enquêteurs
il semble être arrivé à ses fins
bref frédéric on ne sait toujours pas où
il se trouve
non il n'y même s'il est en vie
d'ailleurs en fait il ya beaucoup de
points d'interrogations le plus
surprenant là dedans c'est que les
services de renseignements pensent et
jusqu'il ya peu en fait qu'il serait
toujours en syrie qu'il aurait même peut
être piloté les actes de terrorisme à
partir de là
sauf que des indices et témoignages ont
permis de laisser croire en fait qu'il
était bel et bien en france et même à
paris ce qui en a fait en fait la cible
de l'interpellation de l'année dernière
alors le procureur de la république à
lui confirmé donc il n'était pas il
faisait pas partie des gens qui avaient
été arrêtés et que s'il est parmi les
deux morts en fait il y avait là sa
cousine qui se sert fait exploser donc
la kamikaze mais l'autre personne le
procureur refuse toujours de dire si
c'est bel et bien
about alors est-il vivant est il mort
est il en france ou ailleurs
l'énigme vraiment reste entière pour
l'instant merci frédéric havret